[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya vingt ans des livres qu'ils sont
l'on m'a fait comme moi moi je lis que
des fautifs mais c'est pas intéressant
d'accord
je lis peu de livres mais en fait tout
dépend du livre que j'ai en face de moi
par exemple
par exemple si on me donne un gros livre
avec beaucoup trop de pages et compagnie
ça ne m'intéresse
ça ne me motive quoi c'était aussi p je
me suis enlevé ma maîtresse
la première chose qu'elle nous a fait le
jour de la rentrée elle nous a lu une
histoire et je sais que cette histoire
en fait m'avait marqué et depuis j'ai
toujours eu un livre quelque chose dès
que je monte bière avant livre dans la
main et c'était surtout pour moi un peu
cj jeu pouvait m'échapper si je
m'ennuyais si j'avais des problèmes
c'est comme si un peu mieux mon jardin
secret ou alors des amis que je viens
voir souvent j'aime bien cet aspect de
la lecture qui nous permet d'imaginer ce
qu'en dit la gêner un autre montre avec
une phase plus
c'est mon frère qui m'a donné envie de
regarder en vigueur lorsque j'étais
petit je devais avoir mi temps je ravale
je voyais sur lui regardez de manga du
coup un moment j'ai décidé d'essayer ça
ma passion manga les piments qui a un
peu d'intérêt que le libre j'ai reçu
beaucoup de jeunes pourquoi parce que ça
un mode d'écriture qui leur
correspondent plus et qui est moderne a
motivé sa aussi des personnes sur
clément gasmi ses partenaires ça j'en
fait de leur dire qu'ils sont ignorants
la loi 2010 sauf pour les personnes
âgées ou plus de 40 heures ou 30 ans il
faut souvent kalanga sont utiles que
c'est ça ne sert à rien mais en fait ils
se trompent
il ya 13 ans
jean très charismatique qui nous parlent
de choses dures et profonde
ou alors deux choses simples le site ça
c'était la période cynique la notion de
bien et de mal
pour la ces personnes sont totalement
ignorante vote on a des clients ils vont
acheter de la littérature autant
beaucoup de bd et de mangas
vraiment c'est très diversifié mais la
lecture en littérature rester
[Applaudissements]
c'est un tout
les ruptures par nous expliquer pourquoi
allez occuper petits
déjà j'aime beaucoup poste
m plus que centenaire
parce que
matteo j'aimais importe ton avis
c'est un vieux j'aime panier en 20 58
ans ok quand la main film on sait quand
est-ce que ça agit ni un lien durée
puisque le niveau mon style en toi ça va
prendre du temps ce qui va lentement
enfin c'est lui qui décide vite et bien
gêné en chat de lire
nos amis facilement transylvanie pour la
doc quand j'ai besoin mais faty de me
reposer un peu génie parce que ça me
permet d'avoir une bonne vision sur le
monde sait vraiment ce qui me passionne
l'histoire le fond alors un message qui
vous le cacher derrière que j'aime bien
par exemple certaines histoires d'amour
qui devait dramatique ou alors qu'ils
peuvent se passer bien ou c'est un livre
qui peuvent redonner goût à la vie par
exemple ou même parfois des fictions qui
nous font voyager ou qui nous anime août
quelque part d'un qui ouvre notre pote à
notre imagination
les histoires préférées ce sont les
histoires dans le disque lavage parce
que ça toujours beaucoup de personnes ça
fait partie de notre histoire et aussi
des histoires des violences faites aux
femmes et du savon j'aime bien ces
dissidents lac parce que c'est
magnifique le combat que des gens vont
venir pour réussir à vendre une certaine
ouverture aujourd'hui
j'aime particulièrement ce livre qui à
ce moment-ci
voir
il parle de la seconde guerre mondiale
et il est basé sur l'histoire et donc
tout en racontant
me permet d'apprendre beaucoup plus sur
la date de la déportation des
donc elle et le pardon
être d'approfondir nos connaissances sur
le sujet lire un livre ça permet de ses
adieux ça permet d'imaginer une histoire
ça nous apprend beaucoup de choses alors
je dirais aux jeunes de choisir un livre
pas forcément a grossi ses alliés sur un
sujet que les a7 a6 et verront que ses
talents tels que voilà ça leur permet de
deux rames si le regard des arbitres et
[Applaudissements]
ça va tu vois c'est pas si mal les
produits ça va être intéressant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ces messieurs les lignes
parce que c'est ici un film je connais
désolé préfet s'il est trop bien je te
plaît non et vous à quand la lecture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]